when I was surveying the border from the
air the illegal crossings and the
rescues at the river exploded luckily
Raymond Arroyo and our staff were there
with the border patrol to capture a lot
of the drama
[Music]
where will you intercept them it's the
minute they start getting into distress
this is unbelievable
this got you see a father and I don't
even bother annotation device no so he's
in the water without the babies got the
we got the device on it you're gonna
come this side this is terrifying I mean
if a man separated now you have a man
separated from his baby here the baby's
crying on the other boat and
Border Patrol has left I have to fish
him out of the river and this happens
every day every day all the time from
sunup to sundown with a boat's right
here and they're doing this pretty much
non-stop why risk life and limb this one
many of them just don't want to wait
there's a long way to that the bridges
they can only process so many a day
doesn't matter what bridge they are but
many of them just get tired and they
don't want to wait humane prices and the
prices for humanity is what's forcing
these people here and the entire cartel
that is that has created a network to
fail just so we're seeing the risk to
light the limb and to you guys that's a
low risk in your lab solutely by going
out of your way to protect and in some
cases rescue these migrants aren't you
incentivize more of them to do
we don't incentivize it we try not we
don't want to become a ferry service
alright we know that it's a daily
struggle that these guys have but you
know you can't you can't leave an infant
in the water I struggling you can't
leave small turn don't leave in the
water here we go again these migrants
throwing themselves into the Rio Grande
the difference here contrary to a lot of
the reportage they know they're going to
be rescued because otherwise this
current will carry them straight down
but Border Patrol always intervenes as
they will know
for this gentleman is lady there from
Honduras apparently
there are friends there on the Mexican
mainland who helped them get across
Mexico and here to the Rio Grande and
now they'll go in for process
oh you will cut the man and woman we saw
here the lady claims she's from Honduras
she showed his cuts on her on her arms
on her head you believe this might be
part of a script it very well could be
and we see we see a lot of the same
story do you think these people paid
cartels to get here they're from
Honduras they don't move through here
without the cartels knowing obviously
you see the tragedy of this all around
us where a father and a daughter jumped
into this river thinking they were going
to get some Clements a better life and
they're now going to be taken in process
and then eventually released here into
the country because of the laws the way
they are but they put their belongings
in a bag and they jump in the water and
take their chances this is the situation
here and it really is not only risking
their own lives but the lives of these
agents who are taking us out here